ladies and gentlemen boys and girls I
present to you the world's largest
burrowing clam this is the gooey duck
and oh my god it's an alien look it this
is a gooey duck and well it looks like a
I guess yeah
anyway dickory dock is a type of
saltwater clam that only comes from this
region in the Pacific Northwest they can
burrow themselves several feet
underground which makes collecting them
a little difficult isn't that right
Michael yeah absolutely
so when we're harvesting gooey duck we
use low pressure high volume water the
water comes in through the wand and then
it makes the ground soft enough so you
can stick your arm down three feet to
reach the neck of a gooey duck to pull
it out
majority of the time what you're looking
for is these guys sticking up or these
little holes and that's how you know
where they are and voila
look gooey duck this is the belly the
softest part of the meat of the gooey
duck this is the neck where the majority
of the meat comes from the two siphons
are on the end and they're kind of like
humans where you know they're not all
the same it's just everyone's different
the majority of gooey duck's farm tape
will be sent to East Asia where they are
a sought-after delicacy but here in
Seattle desto big deal and nobody gets
more excited for gooey duck than this
guy so Tom how did you prepare it we
have put it in shouders in the past from
time to time but when you come in here
to eat gooey duck or Taylor shellfish
you're gonna have it raw it's all about
accentuating the freshness of the gooey
duck chilled on the plate with all those
other great fresh ingredients
prepared right the texture of gooey duck
is what really separates it from
everything else you think about it as
having the sweetness of the scallop and
the saltiness of calamari and you have a
really excellent combination
I love eating gooey duck I'll just slice
a bunch put it on a plate squirt a
little lemon throw some salt I couldn't
ask for more and now the most important
part the taste
mmm delicious oh my god gooey duck I
don't think I'm just so sure on that one
anyway well cruise to the new season of
try it you like it where we'll be
dishing up weird and wonderful foods
from around the world which might look a
bit strange but trust me they're
delicious click the link below to find
out more videos from our last season